when we come onto set of the Avengers as
a Guardians we are the guardians and
anybody stepping and once you're set
with us has to deal with all of us we
were kind of cocky deep deep down were
like we're the guardians of girls here
like but um exciting
it would super exciting the fact that
they're bringing every character in the
Marvel Universe together and that this
super villain has is such a prominent
figure amongst the guardians of the
galaxy gives our level of importance
quite a boost there usually one or two
Avengers we are the guardians and we
come as I only carry seen as that we do
business as usual you know which is a
lot of chemistry a lot of interaction
amongst ourselves and the Russos were
very encouraging of that so it's not
really no it's like are they intimidated
walking on set with us no no ma'am
regarding to the galaxy we don't get
intimidated I was a little intimidated
Chris Hemsworth he's so tall and
handsome oh my god I'm an AI yeah I had
dad go home and really look myself in
the mirror and say you know there's a
possibility you just might be one of
those guys who mostly loves your wife
but also kind of loves Chris Hemsworth a
little bit she's done we've talked
[Music]
you
[Music]